[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to channel
awesomes orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Ruth and I'm Ayanna wave and
this is your news for Monday September
18th first up we wanted to talk about
Westworld season 2 news now at the New
York City Comicon we saw a release of
the Funko pop of a new samurai character
named Musashi now it's been confirmed
that the casting for that character in
season 2 will be none other than
Hiroyuki Sanada and so we don't have
really any information on the character
other than it is a full-fledged
character in the show now in the last
season we were revealed that samurai
world exists I'm not gonna give any more
show spoilers for you but we don't know
if he's going to be a guest or a robot
we have no other information than that
we can only speculate we can also
speculate will there be a Roman world
will there be a medieval world such as
the original we already know there's two
worlds now so it's possible why not but
these worlds seem huge so we'll see how
that works also happening at HBO Game of
Thrones is apparently going to be
filming multiple endings because of the
hackings that happened they feel like
this is just the best way to keep the
ending as secret as possible because you
can't have nice things
way to go guys thanks Internet if
anything though I feel like this might
entice some hackers to maybe do the more
likely to do this because there's
multiple endings to be leaked and then
we can speculate what's gonna be
happening what's real we'll just have to
wait and see the real ending will be
filmed live no lie dragon also on
streaming services coming out to watch
soon on Amazon Prime is the season
simply named Lord we both love the
podcast so much we're very excited that
it's going to get its own season now
it's only gonna have six episodes but it
looks like it's going to be chock-full
of
good spooky scary nice yeah I'm really
excited about it it's dropping on Amazon
like you said on Friday October 13th
so it's dropping on Friday the 13th with
I think is some super fun marketing so
movie ideas and two of my favorite
episodes are black stockings and echoes
and I saw a woman being burned and I did
see similar bomb reaction so it looks
like both of my favorite episodes are
going to be within the six episode
series so I'm very very excited about
that if you haven't gotten a chance
definitely listen to it yeah you should
definitely check out the podcast yeah
I'm also coming out and streaming is a
new Blade Runner short so a Blade Runner
did as commissioned three short to
connect the original to the new movie
and already one of those has come out
but now the second one is announced as
in anime which will be super interesting
because it's being directed by Senator
Watson Hobbit who is the director of
Cowboy Bebop
so if you were a huge fan of Cowboy
Bebop which you should be then I feel
like this anime is going to be fantastic
we already know that this director is
strongly influenced by Blade Runner so
he's stoked to be a part of the project
I'm stoked to see this project and it'll
come out on September 26 speaking of
sci-fi things there was a lot that
happened with Star Wars this week the
first thing that we saw was I called it
JJ Abrams is officially the director for
Star Wars Episode nine which seems like
an odd choice to me you know we have the
new trilogy he directed the first one
someone else is gonna direct a directed
the second one and now he's gonna come
back so I mean I think it's a good thing
yeah yeah fine but it just seems like an
odd choice to me and then they also kind
of low-key bumped in there that now the
release date is December 20th 2019 which
is a couple of months behind what the
initial release date was right make
sense
new director gotta have more time adjust
the schedule but bt-dubs
it's not coming out when you expect it
right it'll be the holidays Star Wars
also in Star Wars news there's going to
be a new audio book being released
simply named from a certain point of
view now it's going to be 40 short
stories for the 40th anniversary and
each of those 40 stories is going to be
from a certain characters point of view
and at first we thought maybe it would
be like some niche stories stories that
like weren't major characters but now
we're seeing it is some major characters
that are going to be a part of these
short stories we've got a quote from
obi-wan even a title the time of death
it's going to be his short story so it's
gonna be like his life after his death
so that'll be interesting yeah
force ghost Ness I guess and they had
some huge casting news that came with us
as they released the list of all 40
actors who are going to be a part of
this and the big one that we're focusing
on is that Jon Hamm is going to be Boba
Fett awesome yeah that'll be super cool
really interesting to hear we also saw
that Neil Patrick Harris is going to be
a part of this as well as Wil Wheaton
and ashley eckstein who is not only in
so Titano but also has her own line of
clothing note named her universe and
it's super nerdy well it is most of my
closet is comprised of her universe
clothing so it's great but it'd be
interesting to see if she comes back to
voice a familiar character or if she's
voicing someone new yeah I mean I don't
know it feels like as long as she's
already the character ignite as well but
you ever be it but voice-over actress
trigger she would do except for sleep
ranges and yeah we'll just have to see
and that drops on October 3rd so be
ready for it another movie news there
are some pre-production photo from
Hellboy release Steve David Harbor and I
lost it oh it looks so good so amazing I
was not on board with this at first you
know I was little hesitant a different
different director you know know Gilmore
door Toro you know Ron Perlman
little few about it but then I saw this
photo and I'm on board
I am with it he looks great analytic
work yeah so good his body looks amazing
perfect it looks easy yeah yeah it looks
more metal than rock so I just
it looks more accurate to the comic book
which wasn't that far off to begin with
but it just looks awesome I'm on board
I'm there let's do this so deciding we
can't wait for more information about
film but in the meantime we have a
picture to look at yes
now uh what I'm very excited for in
movie news we had a trailer draft this
week a new one for the disaster artist
and my hype for this film is so real you
guys know real it's so real
now this trailer was a bit different
from the previous one we saw the
previous one seemed to err on the side
of humor it was a very funny take of a
specific scene and the shooting of that
scene and it seemed very funny but it
seemed very much like we were laughing
at Tommy was oh a person a little bit
which I mean if you've seen the room
you've all laughed at time he was always
bright but in this new trailer it seems
like we've really got that heartfelt
backstory like is described in the book
of the disaster artist that the movie is
going to be based off on right and man
ma ma ma feels yeah I mean right oh no I
felt things it'll be a really
interesting look at him like yeah as a
purpose a person like making him more
human almost cousin easy to like see the
stuff that happened with the room and
whatever and feel like he's just some
figure but he's sort of cultivated to
that man of mystery vibe as well
partially on purpose partly by accident
including a billboard that was up for a
while that infamous billboard that just
was Tommy was always face and a number
that you can call now they've actually
brought a new billboard with James
Franco as Tommy was oh his face and that
number and it still works apparently
that's so cool yeah I haven't called it
so
guys call let me know I don't know
random numbers let us know he called it
and what happened yeah but it gives you
information on the film and the original
one took you to his site that he slept -
together and stuff because he wasn't
actually a real producer but did his own
producing man you guys there's so much
mystique around the old film of the room
and I buy into it
he was very interesting to me we still
don't know how he just made like so much
money why did he film it with film and
digital it also he bought his cameras
that's gonna be a scene in the movie I'm
sorry oh my goodness I'm so hyped for
this movie also I think I believe they
pushed it back towards the end of the
year for some Oscar worthy buzz and you
guys oh my gosh circle would that be oh
man I honestly I hope it's a good film
but if it's a good film you can get that
Oscar I know up on that stage are you
kidding wrong just it's almost
incomprehensible io perfect that would
be full circle man my hype is real for
this film so anything else we get I'll
be very excited and eat it up but
otherwise I just cannot wait to see this
film it's really yeah so this week we
got some production photos from the
stage of now we we're having the
pre-release photo is because it's only
on the the pre premier pre-broadway
premiere and that was in Denver this
past weekend so there might be some
changes when it goes to full Broadway in
2018 but for the meantime there they're
going through their paces seeing what
works seeing what doesn't work so I'm
very excited to see like what kind of
songs are added if it's a new songs that
made to make it into the film mm-hmm
stuff like that so I'm very excited to
hear more about that production but
that's some Broadway news for you what
you like Broadway yeah yeah no it won't
go into her clearly until after spring
of 2018 we got a while while it's on
Broadway and let's be honest Lion King
was on Broadway for
so with Aladdin and honestly as frozen
is such the cash cow that it is it makes
sense that it's gonna be on Broadway but
we'll have to wait to see it on tour
that's gonna be it from us here guys
Heather where can people find you on
social media
um you can find me on Twitter at Heather
ruse Instagram at a truce or twitch
twitch TV slash other roofs and then as
usual I'm on facebook as Iona Wade
everywhere else as awesome Ayanna
keeping it simple for you now that's
gonna be it so we'll have to catch you
next week and in the meantime be miss up
[Applause]
you